you might not think to look to a very
zen focused support character for one of
the nastiest damage dealers in overwatch
but then you plays in yada and realize
oh man that monk can do some damage hey
folks Chris waters here with Eric Tay to
talk about Zenyatta how to play this
character how to be on the battlefield
as someone who is outwardly so peaceful
but also super destructive yeah as
anyatta is someone that you know i
picked up at the end of it i didn't
think i was going to like him as much as
I did but turns out he is a DPS monster
but he also can support the team which
is like this fine balance that I've
always wanted in a support character
because I want to do damage as well and
the way he does it is with his orb of
harmony and orb of discord so let's talk
about harmony first that's the most
straightforward one basically it's an
orb you throw on to an ally and it will
constantly heal them while it just
floats over them and follows them
wherever they go it heals at a pretty
good rate it's pretty sustainable I
wouldn't say you know obviously it's not
gonna be as strong as a mercy heal but
it'll do the job and you have to move
that you know to each of your allies
because you know whoever's taking damage
you're going to want to make sure you
move that along because sometimes you
get in a trap of dpsing too much and not
healing your teammates you want to move
that orb of harmony around and
fortunately as a support you see
indicators that show you the health of
your allies so pay attention to these
the color of their silhouette when
they're out of line of sight whenever
that critical red mark comes up you want
to get that orb on them immediately so
you want to be moving this around and
the thing to remember about both harmony
and discord you put an orb on someone it
will stay there indefinitely as long as
they are in line of sight however if
they go around the corner from you if
you can't see them in about three
seconds that orbs coming back to you its
effects are no longer affecting the
target now before we talk about discord
let's talk about housing yada actually
does damage he throws his orbs of
destruction yeah he's got 20 of them you
can either single fire them or charge
them up and shoot five at one time which
is great for you know when you have a
Widowmaker alt or something and you can
kind of see someone rounding the corner
you're like all right I'm gonna cue up
and charge up all five balls and let
them go and you can also use this when
peeking around the edge at a turret or a
Bastian yotta Torbjorn thing but you
want to be really careful because then
Yanis health is so so low even if you
get a shield buff from Symetra and some
armor from Torbjorn you're still really
squishy and so you need to be sort of on
the back line of your team's push you
don't want to be up front you want to be
able to duck
behind walls and duck out of the way of
line of sight especially if you get in
the sights of an enemy Widowmaker or
Hanzo or similar sniper
yeah his orbit of destruction is really
powerful from far away you don't have to
be close up to do the damage you can
almost snipe with them in a way even
though you're not a sniper but that's
how far you can shoot is high feel I
think that's absolutely true and here's
the thing though when you see an enemy
your first click should not be to shoot
them it should be to use the orb of
discord this is a little purple orb that
you will come to love as in yatta
because when it's over an enemy the
damage that everyone on your team does
to them is increased substantially you
put that thing over a road hog or any
other tank and you get a bunch of orbs
of destruction into them you will take
them out yourself
Zen yatta is really vicious but again
you want to throw that orb of discord
that's your first shot it doesn't
technically do damage but that's gonna
allow your second your third your fourth
shots to do so much more and that is
what really amplifies your role as a
damaging support yeah I mean it's a very
scary thing to even have on you and when
you see orbit discord on you're like
well I better hide or miss something
because the damage is coming and it's
real absolutely and if you do hide get a
couple seconds out of the way you'll see
it go away and then you can get back
into the fray highly highly recommended
and duly recommended because the orb of
discord on you means Zenyatta can see
you wherever you are there's a big
marker so he can see you when you're
about to poke around the corner and try
to shoot him he can be charging up his
alternate fire and be up just ready to
dump four orbs into your face when you
poke your head out and you'll be dead
yeah super deadly okay let's talk about
his alt transcendence and this is back
on the other side the support side the
I'm keeping everybody alive side what he
does is he sort of goes into a more Zen
post than his already Zen pose and just
radiates healing all around him and he
himself is invulnerable to damage so
this is great when you are in a
teamfight and you know maybe you've lost
a character or your team health is down
pretty far when you are pushing a
payload or team pushing in on an
objective you don't always want to pop
that first thing you want to let the
fight develop a little bit and then pop
it that's gonna extend the amount of
time that your team is in the fight
together and it's gonna help you get the
most out of transcendence of course you
do want to be careful though even though
you're invulnerable it doesn't mean that
people can't push you away like a
Reinhardt pinning you away or you know
Farra concussive blasting new way so try
to keep your distance from them and kind
of stay near your teammate still but yes
the enemy team has to respect
transcendence because it's a huge AoE
heal that you know is going to keep your
team alive and they can't really hurt
you to get rid of you they're just going
to wait for that thing to end and it
doesn't last terribly long so use it
wisely and you will be well on your way
to being the best zenyatta you can be
you